just gotta squeeze it out you don't have
to put it this
[Music]
my name is Matt Santos I am nine years
old my name is Suri an and I'm eight
years old my name is Kennedy and my age
is boy outside of school
what are some fun things that you love
to do I like to dance
I like to make slime and do gymnastics
my favorite hobbies are like swimming
basketball and other stuff and do you
have a favorite music artist coyote B OH
on a scale from one to ten one being the
worst and 10 being the best how much you
love candy okay nice and sweet and it
gets me hyped I would give it a 9
because candy hurts my teeth but it
tastes like really good like the sugar
in it it's really great so you're
willing to make the sacrifices yeah
uh-huh oh that's it
[Music]
I love fundus good good it's sweet and
it's always sugary you know how people
like share it and then get it back
that's what I'm gonna do they can have
like 102 I taste good I love it
it makes me like crazy I like it
that was delicious I couldn't stop
[Music]
it's like start whatever it is called
why do you think people like bubblicious
back in the 90s that was the only good
bone did you want to try the other gum
or you're gonna save you know kind of
complete this well what one is
strawberry ones watermelon I do not like
watermelons blow a bubble all right
that's good that's all I can give you
[Music]
in the magic beans what is it public so
they pop right
these are sound in my mouth this when
it's parking in your mouth it feels like
we're just like bubbles not that I tried
bubbles it doesn't really taste that
good as your sodium so everything it's
been no
where you had what happened no you don't
have to put it down
I wonder why to calm one head
[Music]
oh why won't this open each go babe
okay still taste it just sour and it
tastes nasty okay would you like to try
another flavor
no why do you think kids in the 90s ate
candy like words because they're crazy
cool like stuff like this would you say
is good though it was really great um
now I wish I was there in the 90s first
of all I would be an adult but um it was
really good it's not really out now
under 2000 so it's good to try it now
my favorite part whether I try the
bubble gum and I liked [ __ ] dick the
flood candies in the 90s were better I
would say they're better than the
candies we have enough I think candies
better down because there's so many
different things s better would you like
that fun dip girl yeah would you try
candies from the 90s again
sure wait
by everybody